um
okay
do
me
miss tilly
i'm afraid i only have a few minutes
let's get right to it
yesterday your network yarovision was
hijacked by rebels
oh don't don't shoot
they called for the liberation of
so-called outcasts from vaviro labor
camps is vivero produced with slave
labor nibiru says millions of lives do
you think that those lives care where it
comes from you were imprisoned at the
age of 13 the same age as diego you
spend a lot of time with your father
he is a great teacher a lion finds calm
before the kill
fire
i understand you were forced to endure
15 years of hard labor pruning tobacco i
hear you still have the blade
when yara becomes paradise
my methods
no one will care
you are the only survivor i watch
castillo order a whole boat of our
people shot to death
get as far away as you can from that
psychopath all of you
a revolution is not won by the fearless
is won by the fear
welcome to libertad danny
i have a vision to rebuild paradise
a cure
fibro the most effective treatment for
cancer the world has ever seen grown
within our precious tobacco but our
paradise comes at a cost this our
enemies will never understand out
now your safety zone
you want me to kill anton castillo
kill a dictator who has raped our land
and turned our people into slaves
thinking about it
what about you
you're gonna be a gary legend
i'm not fearless
but i promise you one thing
i will be here
there are lions there are lamps
you are a lion
and we eat the flames
okay
to
what is going on
[Music]
tell your mother and sister to
you are
alive that is all that matters
peek-a-boo [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] am i
[Music]
i too am a king who isn't afraid to
slaughter to get what he wants
[Music]
is this a test
a dream
an opportunity
then i will not waste it
[Music]
you are beyond salvation
did i ever tell you
the definition of
um
okay
so
foreign
folks welcome to yada i am your host
chris waters joined by my host yousef
mageed here on this special episode of
ubisoft news plays and yes if we have a
special guest here don't we oh we do
chris we are joined by nerd
designer on far cry 6 navi kavari naveed
how are you today
i am good how are you guys doing
naveed we're stoked we are so stoked we
are checking out far cry 6 this is
footage running on the xbox series x now
a few housekeeping notes as we approach
the valle prehistorico here uh this
footage is pre-recorded we've added
together some chunks to give you a great
array of gameplay across the region of
el este here in yara we're going to see
a lot of different action a lot of
different mechanics we'll be talking
with naveed about what we're seeing and
also taking your questions in chat we
are streaming live to twitch
on ubisoft's channel on xbox's channel
and on others we're glad to have you all
there and on youtube as well if you want
to ask questions or uh just holler at us
about what you're seeing join us in the
chat on the ubisoft channel or the xbox
channel and now uh naveed it's time for
a little nature walk here down the old
sendero natural
we are approaching an fnd base
that's right these are anton's military
bases that are throughout yara but
before we get into that i have a
question for you guys okay did you
notice the easter egg that you literally
just drove by
that's the question there was a big old
sabretooth tiger
is that we're talking close
[Music]
there's a pretty there's a pretty big
primal reference
from our friend or something that looks
like a caveman
wait was it
was it visible in the footage that's all
i'm saying that's awesome
cause i'm i'm about to rewind
as one of the writers of eric i i feel
like i had to say something so now it's
out there i don't know if i ruined it
for people now but i i know people in
chat spotted it i don't know if we were
going to run this back
if you want to find this place
it's going to be in the far south east
area of el este now this is a big region
uh here in yara what you uh naveed
there's different regions tend to have
kind of different personalities
different kind of predominating traits
uh talk to us a little bit about where
we're at in ls day
well in ls day you really have the kind
of mountainous uh jungle regions so it's
a lot of elevation a lot of the
grappling hooks and you know sniping
from
statement from mountain heights um and
also it is where it's sort of the
ecosystem of anton's yara this is where
they uh produce what we call the poison
which is the chemical they spray on the
tobacco leaves that produces the the
cancer treatment uh viviro so
there's tons of
of gameplay opportunities as well as
narrative opportunities here with that
poison that that hopefully we see you
engage in but uh
yeah it's highly combustible it's highly
combustible highly bustable
yeah but yeah it's a it's it's sort of
one of the most crucial areas in the
game and it's also
where they ship uh the vivira out so
it's one of the major ports is there
it's all run by admiral benitez
and
mr mckay who
uh
i don't think you're gonna see just yet
but
they have a very dynamic relationship
there's a lot of
we would not be good on team's calls
oh my goodness oh a lot of cutting each
other off
cutting each other off
i like it i'm now i'm going to like
contextualize this a little bit like
these are co-workers right if you're the
leader of you know that you're the
admiral the navy they're supposed to
steal the cabinet yeah
yeah mckay is like an import exporter if
you've ever met someone who says they're
an import exporter immediately they're
doing something illegal so
my great uncle is an importer exporter
and does he always wear sunglasses even
indoors maybe maybe but we don't ask
questions we don't ask questions
yusuf is learning things about his
family we're learning things about far
cry 6 it's a learning experience all
around this morning
uh
now i'm interrupting a lesson here there
people are trying to learn how to uh fly
a helicopter and i'm really trying to do
it a little stealthy here obviously i
didn't quite nail that last machete
thing but like doing a quick study gotta
get the helicopter speaking of easter
eggs there's a little uh get to the
chopper easter egg in that scenario if
you folks take a closer look at that
whiteboard we'll talk look clip it out
clip out these easter eggs i want to see
some clips from this stream a little bit
later on a lot of easter eggs in this
game i can
promise you that well you know you got
so much space to work with and you it's
just like take the alarm
uh yeah the alarms i think are taken out
and so i'm gonna obviously like deftly
make my through this scenario by sliding
off a cliff and landing on my butt
so for folks wondering in uh in chat it
is we're watching chris's gameplay right
now this is not live this is uh
pre-recorded uh gameplay footage um but
we are playing on xbox series x chris
was rabbit uh and this is this is the
only xbox series x footage you're gonna
find today of far cry 6. exclusive we
wanted to give you all something special
today so we're glad you've tuned in now
this is the point where i realized the
design of the via praise story go is
such that
these cavemen are freaking me out i'm
like oh my god there's like 15 guys up
there
oh no it's just this one around here but
like
it was one of those moments of like uh
yeah surprise like oh god
i'm in a situation i hear a helicopter
i mean i gotta give a shout out to uh
you know we you know ubisoft toronto's
lead but we worked really closely with
ubisoft montreal and they actually they
handled a lot of or the majority of lsd
region and
you can sort of feel the the the nods
and the references to the over far cries
and
and they did a fantastic job
now what are you going to do this
chopper what are you doing
here this is our first glimpse in this
stream of a resolver weapon
uh the resolver weapons of course are
the like you know improvised really
heavy hitting weapons that the the
rebels put together
that one in particular is like a sniper
meets a sticky explosive launcher and
i mean
that's the beauty with the
the team that put those together did
such a great job of
allowing you to see
the individual pieces that are scratched
together from
from everyday life thrown together to
make a make a weapon
you know my my favorite is the and it's
a few people's favorite i think is the
el pequeno which is essentially
a motorcycle engine strapped to a turbo
that turns into a gatling gun
that thing rubs up and it's like it gets
pretty hard to control but man does it
mow him down it is so good
we will see a couple more resolve
weapons uh throughout the course of this
stream folks so stay tuned uh we're
wrapping up the fnd base here um but i
also noticed you know far cry is a
series that oh oh man so okay
yeah so this is the supremo backpack
this is the um i forget what it's called
but basically it sends it you can see
the health bar is now yellow i've got a
whole extra pool of health and it allows
me to do machete takedowns on anybody uh
this one is particularly nasty
because you go for the knees first
like that's just so unnecessary it's
like let me let me put you in
excruciating pain before i end your life
there's a special irony that you just
use the medico backpack and then
brutally attacked separately right after
you know this uh you don't win a
revolution by breaking a few eggs i
believe is how the same goes yeah
so now we're going to jump a little bit
to another section of game play and this
is where we're going to meet one of the
revolutionary groups you uh
get entangled with here in far cry 6. la
morale uh navy can you give us the
breakdown on who la morale is
yeah one of the interesting things we
tried to do uh in in ls day is have this
sort of clash of two different groups
um
two different revolutionary groups so
one is the legends of 67 these are sort
of the old revolutionaries in the
mountains and then you have la morale
which is a group of
university students that have banded
together
uh to fight back and they are
very very militant
and and have some of my favorite
characters
in the game and it's one of the things
too that like you look at these
revolutions often as one big group
um but in far cry 6 we wanted to show
that it's actually a lot of different
groups fighting for
fighting for control
yeah
this guy
was about to give us a little bit of uh
an anecdote about la morales operating
methods
so the story he's in the middle of here
is that the admiral executed half this
town for protesting
yeah the thing with la morale is that
you know they're led by
elena who is you know they're all
university students and and and her
second in command
ron who hopefully we get to meet
soon as well
but their methods are uh let's just say
much more brutal
than uh
than the legends and even
libertad they don't care about
clara garcia or libertad or even you
they have their own agenda
they absolutely do yeah on especially is
uh is an absolute firecracker uh yeah i
got to meet her a little bit when i was
playing earlier but i wanted to show off
this mission because this is like you
are basically uh trying to make good
with uh la morale after a little supply
disagreement and uh you're going in to
rescue some captives and of course the
rescue is happening out on this boat
now y'all know how we're getting down to
this boat yeah can you guess how you're
gonna get to the boat
that's the question
oh yeah oh man if i've learned anything
about chris waters from streaming with
him for two years now except this man
loves a wingsuit
oh i'm with you chris
there's two things of far cry 6 that i
need immediately is the wing suit and a
horse and look at his landing look at
this
it's like my proudest moment in this
whole game
well done
well done well done
also we got some folks in the chat
pointing out that there was a canadian
flag flying over this vessel uh naveed i
saw that i wonder i wonder why
mr mckay is in fact canadian
yeah he's a canadian import exporter and
he may or may not talk about
certain timbits
reference
so this is another look at that supremo
backpack now these are these uh things
you wear on your back that you charge up
and can unleash a devastating kind of
ability or something to really help
support uh and this one is the speedy
extra health machete takedowns which you
just saw on display
also you swapped it but the susero el
the nail gun
which is just
perfect for stealth you know there's a
period i think in the project where
everyone is just using el sucero there's
like a two week period where it's like
what are you using also
i was thinking about it before it's like
during the development of these things
you because different weapons are coming
online at different points
you kind of find your weapon and then
you stick with it it becomes sort of
like old faithful
oh yeah and so you got some people
trapped down there yeah i it's the most
unnecessary repel down there but i
didn't really know what i'm getting into
i gotta be safe here
[Laughter]
some people some people play far cry
incredibly stealthy
you know no one sees them coming no one
you know no one they don't make a sound
you just
get rid of the all the enemies on the
entire boat without making a peep not
you not chris waters and you know what i
appreciate that about you
you know there's a lot of ways to play
that's what we appreciate here
my number one method is to attempt
stealth for a solid 15 minutes get bored
and then
go fully loud
with my fuego backpack and just torch
everything
the fuego backpack uh we're gonna
actually see that a little in a little
bit
a lot of flames a lot of flames folks a
lot of flames
not the safest backpack safety is a big
theme of this live stream i think it's
not exactly safe
oh yes
whenever you're overthrowing a you know
dictatorship you always got to be safe
that's the rule number one
chris do you feel like we're judging
your your gameplay right now your play
style
that's live streaming baby i mean even
though this
that was nice
that was perfect let's see see you know
the kids got some chops uh
but no you know folks if you watch
ubisoft newsplays you know that we're
all about having fun with the game like
sometimes we got the plays other times
hey it's a little rough and ready but we
stay positive we have a good old time
and
that's the persian side of me i gotta
make sure you're both okay like
everything's fine
did you need a snack
i like the lightning in this storm was
like very timed at cert there were
certain moments where it was just like
incredibly atmospheric just in the the
timing in the background it was very fun
lsd has some of my favorite sort of set
piece
missions where you just feel like it's
epic and you're going hard and and yeah
this is
this is one of many
and this is one of the ships as well
you know
the sort of navy theme is throughout
they're preventing anyone from escaping
yara um while at the same time funneling
in all the viviro internet
as you shoot down a plane
and engulf yourself in flames you know
look
yes that's exactly what you can look
forward to folks when far cry 6 comes
out on october 7th uh we had some folks
asking about chorizo in chat don't you
worry we're going to get we got a lot of
amigos coming up we've got chorizo we've
got guapo we've got chicharron stay
tuned they're coming you're waiting an
extremely long time to not use chorizo
well here's the thing i have not
recruited chorizo at this point in the
game so we're gonna go and uh we're
gonna recruit chorizo we're going to
meet this absolute uh tyrant of a
rooster
chorizo
like
i don't think i was prepared for how
much of a of a chip on his shoulder
chorizo has like
is just
angry
he's pissed off and it's ready to cause
havoc oh yeah chicharrone is everyone at
18. i think
in 18 you just hit a point
folks as we're uh dealing with a ton of
bombardment and chaos here aboard this
boat feel free to throw a question or
two into the ubisoft chat or uh into the
xbox chat we're taking a look over there
uh i've been seeing y'all chatting there
and so uh
so let me know if you want to know
something uh how old is this
pre-recorded footage samcraft i recorded
this footage uh last week
at the end of the week uh due to some
technical limitations we had to do it
this way just based on the fact of like
keeping everything secure in a
pre-release environment but also this
allows us to like
give you the highlights here and there
and show a diversity of areas of weapons
and everything like that so that's why
we wanted to tune it this way for this
stream for you
my ride is here
james bond exit here
elia who over in the uh xbox uh chat
asking how is uh co-op in the game is it
possible to play through the whole game
in co-op just like far cry 5
it is absolutely possible to play the
entire game in co-op happy to report
that it's an absolute blast playing for
right
in co-op um
and yeah and you will you know
uh there's there's the host and then and
then the co-op player um the host keeps
the
sort of campaign progression but you
keep your
your player progression
it's all your weapons and all of that
stuff as well
so it's pretty real
the resources you gather like
we'll see a little bit of weapon
customization uh in just a little bit
folks but the resources you gather
really go a long way towards tuning
those weapons towards making them uh you
know a lot more versatile and impactful
you need those resolver uh materials
and uh
uh some people are asking as well about
uh crossplay do you know if uh if co-op
crossplay is possible
i believe it is i'm not gonna say a
hundred percent because someone might
throw something at me but i'm i'm pretty
sure it is yeah look
let me investigate i'll we'll follow up
uh try and give y'all a definitive
answer on that one
um this this this ally just happened to
get injured through
no just no no
no fault of my own exactly you know it's
dark entire fall sun is setting
but look
i revived him we get a slow-mo explosion
of the boat it's in the moonlight as
well
yes
oh yeah
i really like that effect the slow down
effect like when the mission is
completed like it's just anything else
it's just like the walk away from
explosions so slowly effect yeah
and there's a there's some open world
mechanics we're going to see a little
later as well that are like uh
you you start to cause a lot of trouble
you're gonna trouble's gonna find you in
addition yeah you know you seeking it
out
gotta be careful that's that's one thing
you know we talked a lot with our
designers and and our world director
uh ben hall you always wanted that
feeling of the world pushing back you
know so it's not just like you uh
you're going about and the world doesn't
exist around you
and yeah if you start messing with it
anton will send his special forces
oh chicharrone
oh here we go
ripped off his arm
yeah shout out to jandy and chad that
says damn that rooster had drips
oh yeah
and yes he just the way he says cheat
your
there's like the longest period where
people are just yelling that on the
floor it's like a battle cry
there it is
regret not going paperless
not going paperless not going paperless
right right she's your own first and
foremost is an environment
very environmentally conscious in far
cry 6.
i really like the that kind of mission
briefing because you get so much
character from the mission
and it really like helps paint this
picture of who this this maniacal
rooster is
and what's different let's go around is
you get a lot the the sort of mission
briefings you get we get a lot closer
you know with the
with with the characters you get to see
all the little details in their face and
their their clothes and their gear and
and all that what are you gonna pick
chris
well we're still pretty early on here so
i don't have a ton of weapons unlocked
so just mixing it up
uh one of the hardest thing with game
dev is tell me when
you know you uh
you actually play the game as you should
play it and you can't just use cheats
so like every time i play a game once
it's released
like all like my hand is flying all over
the controller and everything's i'm like
what is going on where are all my like
my cheats man where's the stuff
where's my stuff
uh we had a question here who was just
saying this about um
can you hide the mini map yeah there's a
ton of like hud customization stuff you
can do tons
uh so you can yeah that's that's
something that i wanted to leave it on
just so y'all could see how it goes but
you tune in in about a month to our live
streams once this game comes out we'll
we'll we'll play around with the hud
we'll we'll see what we can do sure yeah
yeah you want to take off the mini map
the health bars you could do all that
now we're getting a look at the exact
opposite oh you want it
i want everything up
again look at some of the arsenal here
you've got your supremo backpack in the
main slot three primary weapons and a
sidearm and then five gear pieces uh and
there's a lot of different ways to like
customize the whole operation plus your
look because with your get with your
cosmetic gear sorry with your what
you're wearing you can do like a
cosmetic customization and swap out the
look and keep the stats uh which i know
use of you are still that's a that's a
shift is the uh
is your progression is tied a lot to
your to your gear which is a bit which
is gives you a lot more freedom in terms
of your play style
um that i think folks are going to
appreciate
and one of the things i noticed about
the gear was that some of the stuff i
was like i was kind of expecting it to
you know as it does sort of amplify
certain resistances and powers but one
of the gloves was like
you're you when you catch on fire the
fire will be put out because of these
gloves and one of them there are some
shoes that were like you resist getting
knocked over by melee attacks
put these on i need those yeah and
whether it's whether it's weapons or
gear you know if you you know wear a
certain vest that'll repel you know the
poison that the army throws you like so
you're kind of problem solving depending
on the situation
look at this chicharron waits for nobody
speaking of problem solving just
starting things
that's that's what we wanted to get
across with the chitrarone
is
you don't know if you're fighting with
him or he's fighting with you you don't
know what he's fighting
but there's fighting
our mission here is to protect teacher
owen i don't feel like teacher needs any
protection
no no not really i think the rest of the
world needs protection from children
yeah yeah oh god what is this weapon
chris
oh this i feel like this is just
we're actually going inside the
fireworks wait am i going to use the
fireworks
i don't want to kill chicharron
you'll see some fireworks later don't
worry that's like uh you know chekhov's
fireworks launcher we'll see some in act
three
now um speaking of sure at the moment
you mentioned the fire earlier
being a favorite and i wanted to shout
it out because that's where it is
i love this one saved it for the
document
the library basically
to unload
absolutely so far craig look chicharron
hates these documents and i'm trying to
help out my little buddy here that's it
man the moment
i think the turning point with chicharon
was when he got the collar once he got
the punk rock collar
everything sort of fell into place
i'm digging those like neon spurs or
whatever i don't know what you call them
those like the back like claws
uh so folks uh asking i do have some
clarification on uh on co-op so co-op is
possible between um generations of the
same platform so like xbox one to xbox
series x and s uh it is not uh available
uh across
the system so xbox and playstation uh
cross play is is not there but uh cross
saving cross progression is live for
everyone so uh if you own the game on
multiple platforms you have one save
your save carries over from from one of
the one to uh the next
there you go
uh two notes uh before we as we continue
uh we will see some more looks of
chicharron because you can customize
sort of you can get your amigos in
different outfits we're going to see a
little bit of those later also if you
want to go back and pause the stream
when we were just looking at that
document you can learn a little bit more
about elena the leader of la morale that
we were talking about earlier that
naveed uh who naveed was talking about
uh that was like a little dossier on her
and you can see exactly what kind of
threat the army thinks she is
now chicharon in addition to having like
a endless bloodlust uh and hatred for
the castillo soldiers
also like he's got an ego man you need
he wants people to know that he's been
here so the way this is conclusive
he's the [ __ ] of the walk he's a rooster
he's uh
he's showing off
absolutely so you gotta let folks know
who it was who was the one who trashed
this building
[Music]
nothing like an abruptly ended screaming
guitar solo now we have one more t-shirt
on mission before he we can recruit him
as an amigo and we're going to hop into
that now
uh before we do that folks just a quick
note about the footage you're seeing
it's it ran on it's captured from an
xbox series x pre-recorded so we could
show you a bunch of different segments
and edit them together so we have chunk
here chunk there jump there uh and of
course we're streaming it at 1080p 60
frames a second because that's sort of
our optimal like uh how we want to
stream to you but of course settings
will exist for a higher graphical
fidelity and whatnot as your home setup
permits show them the meaning of
strength
one of the things i want to point out uh
briefly naveed that i'm a big fan of and
you know we talked a little about about
gear outfitting your danny with with you
know what you want them
uh
you know what gear you want them to have
and the stats that come along with it
but the thing i'm really big fan i'm
really glad you all have this in at
launch is being able to customize the
appearance of those gear items
so
folks basically the way it works is if
you have a piece of gear you like the
stats of the piece of gear but maybe you
don't like the look of it necessarily
you can swap out the appearance with
another gear item of the same category
that you already own which
i think it's a mask especially
it's a huge roster there's so many
things to choose from um as you unlock
them but the thing that i think the
reason i'm so happy about this naveed is
that far cry 6 has third person cut
scenes for the first time so you're
seeing your danny a lot more than you
would normally see a far cry absolutely
yeah and that that was a big uh let's
see if it works moment
several years ago that thankfully paid
off but yeah that was one of the reasons
we wanted to do
uh third-person cutscenes not only that
you're sort of more
invested i love how angry at the
mongoose he is first of all
not having it but yeah it's uh
it's one of those things where you get
to be a bit more invested in danny's
story but also you get to see you know
your danny uh you know doing their thing
and interacting with the characters so
um it instantly worked when we tried it
out it was fantastic
just it's just he doesn't hold back does
he no oh no
[Music]
right
because he knows what's gonna happen he
knows
so the for folks who missed it this
mission right now we have to keep
chicharon alive while he wrecks the
monument now i've seen people call this
a follow and protect mission if you're
watching chicharon in action
it's not it's like it's make a follow
and keep up because yeah yeah
come along
it is so vicious chicharron is batman
and you're robin here definitely a high
chaos amigo we'll see we'll see a
stealthy amigo uh situation with chorizo
in just a little bit
um
and one of the games we played
the writing team was
eric mercic and
and the writers over in
montreal was to see how many times we
could get the word chicharrone in
the dialogue
so if you play it it's like chicharron
is either in every sentence or every
other sentence
it's just one of those nerdy little
things oh it's so fun to say now i want
to talk about this resolver weapon it's
called elmuro which means the wall if
i'm not mistaken uh because you got this
huge shield and then basically a
revolver shotgun
and then we've got these players
shotgun at that yeah there we go
uh so when things get hot having elmuro
around is really helpful because you got
that big shield you can also melee with
that shield
so good it's so good
i like that that that little table there
is all set up for like a nice
salt like it's where the champagne
glasses is for the soldiers to like
inaugurate this before this situation
and of course
what far cry is complete without a
little grenade well you talked about the
the resolver weapons and and even with
the
way you customize your weapon
different optic sights and that kind of
thing there's the philosophy in far cry
6 from juan cortez or
our gorilla spymaster of just the right
tool for the right job so if there's
there's a job you want to get done
you'll find the right tool right so
whether that's a resolver weapon whether
that's a supremo
um
you can adapt to any situation
super fun
absolutely and here's that el moro again
how hard this thing hits is just so
satisfying i love the idea of it having
a shield too
yeah
you like it even more when you're like
literally catching on fire right
now
wait speaking of that i'm so happy you
got on fire there chris
i think any any far cry
veteran has
caught themselves on fire you know one
or two or you know
dna
yeah
there's a mission fairly early on in the
game where uh you uh you're giving
you're given the flamethrower for the
first time but you're also given fire
and apparently
yeah a pair of gloves though
that uh that that you know it's a gear
item and their unique ability is that if
you are caught on fire you are
automatically put out
because of these gloves oh yeah
and it was a complete game changer
yeah
there's so many things like that and
that's that's sort of what i'm getting
at the right tool for the right job like
you you know whether it's you know
armor-piercing rounds you know vests
that you know repel poison fire that
kind of thing or gloves
you know shoes that'll help you go a
little faster that type of thing it's
it's one of those things that you really
can you have so much freedom to do what
you want
um
i'm just in all you really like this
so it's hit so hard but this isn't this
is one of the enemies that really
surprised me because it's you know
they've obviously got the helmet they've
got the helmet but this dude is also
throwing down deployable shields like
and taking cover behind them they're
tenacious but we have solutions for that
as you can see oh the exterminator
i swear to god once the exterminator
came online that is all i used for a
solid like three months
chat is loving me so satisfying
so satisfying it is so good and then oh
here we go there he is
oh it's coming he sure does
where is he
there he is
this is
being like you're cool we're good
now we're friends
you've created a binary um
now we can all go home happy now i did
not see this question in chat but i know
it's in the back of your mind folks can
you pet
the cheat your own
we have answers for you here uh
exclusively on ubisoft well no i'm not
exclusively just it's gonna happen right
now you're going to see what happens
when you try to go in for the scritches
back up back up it's not having it mind
your business chris you could you could
not pet the roosters
you cannot uh quick uh i want to address
a question in chat folks are asking
about some pc specs um and you know
console specs more information is going
to be posting on that pretty soon if
you're curious how it's going to run on
your pc what kind of settings you can
get into we're gonna have more
information on that keep an eye on
news.ubsoft.com
in the lead up to the release which is
just over a month away far cry 6
launching on october 7th
uh
and you know the soldiers here trying to
try to make a nice monument so they're
setting themselves
not happening it's funny with the pet
animate the pet animations are the ones
that so much love goes into and so much
personality and that goes all the way
back the team at toronto a lot of us
worked on primal and that's kind of
where a lot of that kicked off and like
people make there i i can't wait for
people to make their little
the sort of you know youtube comp reels
of all the pet animations and things
like that you're gonna pet the horse
yeah yeah you were you put the horses
yeah you are chris absolutely yeah you
are listen of course give people what
they want naveed you know
you know it you know they want it we
know they want it so we've gotten two
we've got cheat your own pets we've got
horse pets i think we've got two or
three more coming in the stream uh
assorted pets so and i'll tell you like
there are so many amazing ways to get
around
yara flying cars and
all this [ __ ] the horse is my number one
go-to
like it's it just works so well and i
don't get nauseous on it which is
amazing if you've ever been horse riding
like
this is not actual horse riding it's
like what you think horse riding is
gonna be like it's perfect
it's what it should be horse riding is a
lot more uh
discomfort as you
i don't know man
the first time i trotted on a horse it's
basically
uh i need to time it right you got to
time it because otherwise you're just
like butt to saddle absolutely just
getting like
tenderized
uh so i finished that situation i a a
dude rolled by on a horse i said that's
my horse now thank you
and then just kind of like rode over the
hill because i was like ah
maybe i'll go find something and lo and
behold stumbled upon this military
ambush site at these uh out on the
outskirts of this like little
agricultural complex
uh and here is where we're gonna do a
little stealth folks
you guy has some stealth chops we're
gonna see some stealth here okay okay
chris i know yeah you said if i know you
pressure's
uh we got some folks wondering about so
we're scouting we got our little uh our
little binoculars here folks are
wondering about turning off health bars
and stuff like that there's a lot of hud
customization that you can do and i
believe that as among uh and you're
going for that air drop over there that
orange smoke yes you want some of that i
want that
well because now you craft your your
weapon upgrades all that
business yeah i as i was playing i was
sort of getting more of a idea for what
what upgrades do what and so now you see
the amigo menu and you're giving the
fans what they want we do but look so
there look at chorizo's abilities as you
use his abilities you can unlock new
ones uh you know feel free to just go
back and clip this out here folks
these tiny legs
they're so small
so yeah
[Music]
this is like a real crafty one i like
that oh
this oh there you go
the moment i've told this story before
but the moment the concept of chorizo
was done the next day everyone's
wallpaper was chorizo and just like just
a sea
of chorizo monitors as far as i could
see
it was fantastic
all right so we went with bling chorizo
of course those are just cosmetic things
uh but
they matter
and now
the amigos have their little abilities
right you're going to kill them with
kindness now is that uh
well trees let's make an appearance
shortly but i do also really like this
move here because i'm dragging this body
behind me and i really like it's a great
uh and i i don't know if it's the first
time i've encountered it but it just
like felt like so natural to be like
look i don't want to hoist this guy on
my shoulder right now i just want to
drag him into the shadows
and it was so smooth i really liked that
uh and now we see the see the good boy
go to work
this
look at this
how are you not gonna doesn't get better
than this how are you not gonna try to
see what's up
uh now navi did you have any um
did you have any sort of model work for
chorizo did you did anyone on the team
have their little wiener dog yeah
i i swiped one
of them it's this weird shaped chorizo
uh
plastic thing but
the best was on the mocap floor we
created a model chorizo with wheels and
like like wood oh my god it was nowhere
it was actually kind of scary to look at
because it had like
no eyes and
but uh
but still you got the emotion you get
the emotion out of it the emotion
i am waiting for my chorizo plushie i'm
still wait i keep i think i send a
message probably once a week about that
like where's where's the plushie now you
can send them this clip be like you
understand the lengths i'm willing to go
to to get this plushie
yeah exactly i was you know we didn't
have e3 this year but i was like maybe
there will be chorizo cannons at e3s
they just fire the plushies into the
i had a lot of ideas
yes
uh kiba i see you in the chat i did best
boy was a good clarification there
called chorizo
but come
the best boy
he's looking around he's trying to mix
it up
oh my god oh my god
so cute
i love that he's so full of joy and then
he just like watches me totally machete
slaughter somebody was like yeah he's
got a bit of a dark shirt
chorizo has seen some [ __ ]
yeah
james has seen a lot
you know what if if i have to go you
know i want the last thing uh i
experienced to be the joy in trees
just so happy to watch the machete go
into your throat
uh sushi kaya i see asking in the xbox
chat is anton the only villain
look you don't get to be the head of a
nation without having some allies am i
right naveed
yeah absolutely the uh anton has sort of
his
cabinet so to speak uh so there's
there's multiple villains in far cry 6
covering different aspects of his
his sort of uh regime and yeah in the
east it's uh admiral benitez so she runs
the navy
and and
the military in the east
and then you have mr uh
mr mckay who is the aforementioned
import export but each
each sort of region of the game has
their their sort of uh
deputy to castillo
uh that you're going to run into
we got some amazing performances uh from
these folks uh
so i can't i can't wait for it to drop
just count the days oh yeah oh yeah not
far not far now
so this is actually a two sort of two
little open world kind of objectives
here it was to complete the ambush uh
but there's also a supremo bond i mean
you know what that could be you need
that gun powder and you need that
supremabond you heard it here make sure
you hang on to that
that's how you get the resume weapons
and the depleted uranium i don't know if
you you're going to manage to get some
depleted uranium
but now look folks oh my god
we know we know what you can do there it
is
there it is
look at this
he's so small
i think he can drop the mic now and just
walk away i mean look there's more
control here
[Laughter]
you know it's funny you say that because
we actually are the the stream will end
on a pat
at the very end spoilers spoilers and
then uh once this stream wraps in a
little over 15 minutes we got bonus
gameplay footage coming for you on the
xbox twitch channel we'll tell you all
about it at the end of the stream here
uh but first we got both stuff up
wait did there's pretty important those
uh aaa cannons are protecting the skies
so you know you got to take those out in
order to to fly around with your
choppers and flying cars and whatnot so
listen was i shot down with an a from an
aaa gun yes
now we're taking a look at guapo oh
yeah
if you don't know you know how i knew
guapo you know how i knew guapo was the
the right name document is we had just
named
guapo
guapo
and we went to do casting and i stepped
out of the the hotel and this car i'm
not even i'm not kidding pulled right up
to me and it just said guapo on the
license plate this was like the day
after we named it that was like the
stars are lighting here
it's perfect
naveed i gotta ask because i i i don't
think this is what you meant but just in
case it is i gotta ask
you just started a cat were you casting
in the crocodile
[Laughter]
it's a good one no
[Music]
i i we did not have to cast the
crocodile i wish okay okay have you ever
ever held a croc before
oh no i don't know did you say killed a
croc
yeah
i've held one yeah really it's very
weird if you held the pick up full size
oh baby oh not full it was like mid mid
size
you feel everything
when you hold like it's like this thin
layer of skin underneath and you just
all its organs are there
oh anyway this this took a turn
you said that i was like
you feel everything like your own
mortality like eons of evolution
that as well
you really rethink your choices
okay buddy
wait chris we need to acknowledge this
weapon you're using because you're using
the macarena cd launcher yes this is the
disco
listen if uh if if you got a crocodile
around things are getting loco
i i was hearing this on play a little
bit is it when you abs is it when you
aim down sights that the song starts
playing yeah cb starts spinning start
spinning let's see and that's where the
haptic feedback comes into play as well
because i think you just hold it down a
little you can just play the song so uh
we play a lot with a haptic feedback
here
that's pretty neat now i put this jersey
on a little shout out to the bay area
folks there uh we got some classic
warriors colors oh yeah of course but
there's a guapo move coming up here it's
like a very crocodile move which i
that's why i wanted this clip this clip
to be included because it's so cool
yeah it's a very crocodile move
quintessential croc uh as we ride up
here into the
sun i think i believe this is sunrise
i still can't get over the idea of of
casting a crocodile just going to like a
big casting call i picture all of them
sitting in like a waiting room together
just like very nervous like going over
their lines
i i gotta give a shout out to like our
team and our 3d team and our programmers
like
you you're sort of riding by it but
you got rain in this game you got
tropical rain happening oh yeah and that
was the feat uh to pull off and it just
looks gorgeous
and it's like a sunshine right here the
xbox series x yeah
oh it's great
the game is stunning this is going to
run off now here's our crocodile moment
[Music]
oh boy
oh
guapo
oh the the spin like the death spin or
whatever i'm sure there's some technical
classic croc girl rock roll
death roll says lagging in there
yeah i mean it's so gnarly now we're
getting we're just going to do a little
some some exploration uh a few little
vignettes here before we get to a final
kind of uh outpost takedown in a little
bit uh but if you know me you know that
in addition to high chaos i'm also
really down with the aerial takedowns
chris i'm impressed you made me happy
there that was that was impressive i
knew you'd enjoy that one thank you
thank you
what's super fun is just to listen to
the radio and drive around to be honest
like
just a ride
and the music yeah there's such a
diverse array of music in here that will
pop up as you're playing i like it also
one of my favorite things is when music
is playing in other cars that just drive
by because like that happens a lot on my
street you know it feels like
it feels like part of the bigger world
part of your community just like
listening to music as folks our audio
director uh eduardo weissman and and and
his team including greg newby they spent
so much time
looking for artists specifically latin
american artists that would just feel
great and unique to
yara so
yeah it's it's a trip man just drive
around enjoy the sunset and that's the
you know i don't know if you're gonna i
think you're sort of doing it here but
that you can holster in far cry 6. oh
yeah i can't stress this enough how
different an experience it i mean you're
not doing that now
but it's from downtown
that's it that's it got some steph curry
actually
but if you holster it's a totally
different experience then these dudes
roll up because so this is like these
guys have hunted me down
so of course well you've been
causing some damage now chris
and this
that horse is on fire that horse is on
fire
yeah this is yeah so i actually that's a
unique weapon in addition to picking up
sort of the the highly customizable
weapons you can also pick up unique
weapons so it's got unique cosmetic if
you line the the tape or the clip back
once this streams over you'll see the
different look to it um and it's also
got incendiary rounds as we saw
and i think i got that from doing a like
a grand grand prix race in this area
so if you're looking for it that might
be a place to check out folks
this is ls day region again it's in the
southeastern part of the map it'll all
make sense to you once you play the game
in just over a month october 7th it's
coming
you can head over to that workbench
chris you know have some fun over here i
am naveed i am
going to mess around here this is we're
actually going to see because it's
slightly out of order we're going to see
me customizing the file which i used
in one of the earlier clips so
you know checking out the various sites
you can put on uh and doing a little
customization here
while while we were watching this chris
navita i want to go back to something
that you brought up but we didn't quite
we didn't quite uh get to address it
completely the holstering your weapon
and how how much that that change is
gained but what does that do exactly
well it's something that hasn't existed
before in far cry where you holster and
you can
sort of blend in you know no one's going
to really uh
you're just going to be in you know an
average yarn walking around so it's good
for
you know if you want to go
go find a treasure hunt or you want to
just you know take in the sights and and
drive around and and that kind of thing
walk around and enjoy the sunset so to
speak
uh but it's also good for ambushes it's
also good for you know sneaking up onto
the military um
and yeah it's one of those things that
that when we
when we put it in there um you realize
how much of a difference it makes it
just makes the world feel a lot more
realistic
um and and those ambushes are satisfying
people
oh holstered up yeah
well i was well i really love the
holster effect because they also get to
like see more of the uh the environment
and stuff like that uh now we're gonna
see here uh this is well obviously a
gnarly takedown but this is a
another resolver weapon uh
it shoots like emps that stun people as
you can see oh yeah but i didn't realize
that it was not fully deadly so i turned
around and was like uh
oh god
um
he went back to old faithful see look
i'm trying to stay alive here
[Laughter]
uh but just to note on keeping it
holstered i also i came across an enemy
who
he was just on patrol in like a
lighthouse or something and he
i was able to approach the soldier and
bribe him to get a bunch of locations of
resources
uh whereas if i had my gun out it would
have had we would have duke it out um so
some strategic advantages in terms of
like who might be willing to help you
out as well
yeah and it's uh it's one of those
things that you you got to keep your eye
out for remember that you know that's
something you'd find in a in a
revolution is there are soldiers out
there that
you know they're willing to play both
sides a little bit so it's one of the
one of the best ways to get intel of the
region what's going on whether it's
treasure hunts or
you know like the grand prix races or
that kind of thing
um i'll see that there you go right tool
for the right job right
and that helicopter did not blow up as
you'll see here i mean i think it might
end up blowing up a like beauty
because he threw a grenade at it
i don't want that helicopter i don't
want it i'm not mad that it's gonna blow
up but
i think it actually no i think it took
back off that's the thing oh okay okay
the truck the truck blew up
[Music]
and then like was able to take back off
so i'm gonna have to bring it back down
uh yeah
definitely a great way to like
and so this is like
how do you get a helicopter it's not
crucial he got exploded or something but
look like it's also crucial for tanks
you know not just choppers like you
you gotta be a little creative sometimes
you're not gonna be able to take a tank
you know with your rifle necessarily but
you might be able to do some emp on it
and steal it for yourself
stealing it for yourself i mean for sure
that's the name of the game
that is that's
right there
all right here we are up at the roca
pequena
sat station
another fnd base uh and we're gonna do a
little take down here will it be
stealthy will be not uh you're gonna
find out
y'all gonna find out
and that is the el sucero
uh and this is one of those weapons like
the bow where
you look at the body and you can see a
large nail sticking out of it
just like morbidly fun but true to life
first we gotta check out some different
looks for our oh look at this
look at this our lad chicharron looking
hot chicharron
party oh my god
tyrone
yeah there's a tradition of far cry
like descriptions uh text like little
mission descriptions of being
like y'all get funny with it
that is where the most freedom is
because no one's looking on the team
are you gonna
once it's out there it's out there it's
too late
um but the team uh they spent so much
time and love
uh that i think the fans
uh are gonna they're gonna lose it a bit
there's tons of easter eggs jokes and
and just amazing work they've done
definitely worth uh yeah reading the
reading the descriptions checking out
your mission objectives and whatnot
because the the writing there is real
fun
i'd like you to know that i did not just
step on a grenade thank you very much i
was wondering if you're going to lure
the guy over
we're not that advanced naveed that's
why we
have to give us the pro tips folks
here's a pro tip from your friends at
ubisoft news plays lure enemies onto
tripwires and they'll blow themselves up
that's why you get two that's why you
got chorizo
that's it
oh man chorizo just watching it
[Laughter]
oh absolutely gnarly i love it
i mean i gotta say that the one thing i
also appreciate about all this stuff is
the the audio design here the propaganda
it's all custom everything you're
hearing is
is custom we got a marching band from uh
um
from latin america to do like the anthem
so it's all unique
uh tiara they did an amazing job
there is uh if you folks go back and
watch the first base takedown there is
some propaganda from anton describing
like what is a rebel and like talking
about how they are like you know maybe
it's a defective character or like a
failure like just like absolutely
eviscerating who he thinks the rebels
are
and it's it's savage like he's we we did
all that propaganda a lot of that
propaganda recording in one day so
there was like a solid two hours of
me getting indoctrinated by uh
giancarlo
oh
that's the poison that you just launched
and it's going to make them go a little
crazy now
and potentially start shooting each
other yep and so
one goes down and then
we bring out the fireworks
i told you they were coming i told you
they were coming folks
delayed satisfaction
it's fantastic
oh yeah
and like there it is look at this
it's so good use if i know that's your
favorite uh oh gosh health healing
animation thus far
anga sac saying this firework cannon is
a dream come true it's so good and uh
might i recommend this next move folks
finishing the base takedown with the
firework kill
will get you just like
the festive yes
there you go that's celebration right
there
wasn't that something that happened in
far cry 5 when you you took out an
outpost like i think it would shoot off
fireworks
there's a very big fourth of july uh
element to far cry 5
now uh we are winding down this gameplay
segment here folks we're going to take a
nice little plane ride uh we will end
with another petting of a creature in
this world and then we'll send you off
to another
live stream over on the xbox twitch
channel with more gameplay from far cry
6 uh an area that we do not explore in
this so it's going to be new stuff for
you to check out that's coming soon
stick with us
uh i love that you keep trying the pet
chicharron and
you just don't get it
look i just wonder it's like i told you
what i thought that's true that's true i
just want to express
my i don't know admiration i guess would
be that
mutual respect
mutual i do feel there is a certain
amount of mutual respect there's a
certain amount of chaos action that uh
the teacher own sees me engage in and i
believe she's a kindred spirit
superman
[Laughter]
scissor random chat says that was a
weird looking dog
[Laughter]
that's true
we got some aerial flight happening you
know we're just trying to check out the
scene just like getting a lot of
verdance tropical vibes here uh
you know if you heard yusuf before and
if you know our streams you know how
this flight's gonna end
and it's not with parking uh airplane on
a runway without safely landing the
plane
yeah my favorite move is to jump out of
the plane and use it as a torpedo
on oh is that what did i well not the
second part oh again i didn't
again it's a big brilliant
flats
that's just going to go somewhere i
don't know uh sorry to
sorry or you're welcome to whoever that
lands on sorry
sorry if you're welcome
next time i greet somebody
it's been great sorry or you're welcome
now naveed
uh in the in the closing hours while we
have you here uh you have been you know
narrative director on this game for some
time now we're nearing release uh what's
kind of what do you feel and like are
you excitement is a relief is it just
like what are you looking forward to for
launch uh in just about over a month
here
it's it's excitement i think i'm you
know i might sound a little cheesy but i
think i'm just excited for the team
more than anything you know you
we've dreamed and worked and and bonded
and
we've gone through so much so much life
can happen in five years like my beard
was black you know whatever it started
this game
so
um i think the team has just
i can't emphasize enough how big and
dense this game is and they've put every
piece of themselves into it and i think
i'm just more excited for the team to
finally get to see everyone enjoy their
their hard work man you know excellent
and folks
yes you can bet the dog
[Laughter]
oh here first there you heard it here so
that is going to be the end of our game
gameplay on the xbox series x here
during this live stream but there's more
far cry 6 gameplay coming your way and
here's what's gonna happen if you're
watching this stream on twitch.tv xbox
i'm gonna stop sending that signal so
your channel is gonna go dark for a
second but a new stream is going to
start that's the one that's going to
have new gameplay if you're watching on
twitch.tv ubisoft we're going to send
you over there so you all need to just
sit tight and if you're watching
elsewhere there's more gameplay coming
up on xbox's twitch channel you can find
your way there so first things first
we'll say farewell to xbox stream thank
you for joining us come check us out
soft news plays we live stream uh next
on friday at 10 a.m on this channel
we'll see you then
now for everyone else who's still here
we're gonna give xbox a second and then
we're gonna raid you on over to their
channel uh from the twitch
uh ubisoft channel uh naveed next up
we're gonna be checking out i believe
some isla sanctuario uh give people a
little what what's what's what's that
place like what are people in for
well isla santorio is a is a smaller
island just off the the coast of yara
and uh essentially it was the landing
spot for libertad's first attack so
clara garcia attempted this attack with
juan cortez and a small
little group of guerrillas but they were
outed so they they just got completely
decimated
and now castillo has formed a blockade
around the island and unfortunately that
is where danny is uh you are thrown into
um after confronting castillo so
you gotta meet clara and you got to help
some some libertad folks and that's
where we are going to be throwing you on
this raid from the ubisoft channel if
you're not raiding with us on the sub
channel go to twitch.tv xbox now to
check out the live stream or the vod
once it's all complete naveed thank you
so much yusuf thank you so much folks
far cry 6 coming on october 7th be sure
to check it out catch you later
take care y'all thanks guys thanks
everyone
you